[Music]
all right good evening it's great to see
you all here I'm Alexander Rose I'm the
executive director here at the long now
foundation as many of you know before
these talks we usually do
what's called a long short a short film
that somehow exemplifies long-term
thinking or is on the theme of the
night's talk and tonight's long short
was actually chosen by our very own
Stuart brand and it has both David Byrne
as well as our founding board member
Brian Eno enjoy
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
so the one way
and son
shouts and bad
[Music]
[Applause]
I can see
[Music]
when the
right
[Music]
[Music]
wait face-to-face
even
this man
everything can change that one fine
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
remember former
it's standing still Bobby
[Applause]
a complete
[Music]
[Applause]
when I am done they're happy so
[Music]
where
[Music]
to God
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
hi I'm Stuart brand from long now
foundation
that song was basically co-written by
Brian Eno and and David Byrne and Brian
is to the local angle it's the one of
the founding board members and still
present board members of the long now
foundation so for one fine evening
please welcome David Byrne
[Applause]
thank you thank you very much this is
kind of two things mashed together but I
think I think it's gonna work no that
that thing so a few years ago probably
like a lot of us I would wake up in the
morning and read the newspaper and
become very agitated and depressed and
angry and I decided to try kind of self
therapy which was when I was found
something that made me feel a little
hopeful I file it away in a little
folder and after a couple of years I
found that there was quite a number of
things there and I started calling them
reasons to be cheerful and it gave me
and they got to be a little more
organized I realized that I mean it
sometimes I'd put things in there like I
went out and heard some music and it was
really great and it made me feel great
that I thought is not not something
that's going to help anyone else really
that much so I started being editing
things a little bit more and I collected
a lot of them and posted them when I
could recently I realized I wanted to
take it a little more seriously so
basically we have shut down what what me
posting stuff and I've hired some
writers and editors and designers and
this and that we're going to try and
relaunch in August and do it a little
more seriously and more write in more
regularly but I'll give an example of
some of these things and then I'll segue
into the second part so this is one that
hasn't been posted yet this is about
homelessness and this man is Elijah
Stevens and he's in the conservatory
Music Conservatory he's doing quite well
he used to be homeless
this man is Pat Lawson he's well
obviously a bus driver and he used to be
homeless
this man is Amos niat a he is a heads a
construction crew in New Zealand and he
used to be homeless this is the work of
a woman named Karla Dickens in Australia
and she used to be homeless so that's
just the beginning so I I dread started
reading some things about solutions for
homelessness and I found out that one
thing that's being done seems to be
having a lot of success and that's
something called housing first housing
first is well exactly what it says it
says that you give people who are
homeless you give them a home and then
but by definition they are no longer
homeless okay it doesn't end there of
course as a woman in works in New
Orleans said you you have to accept them
as they are if if they're they were an
addict if their life was a mess if
there's drunk sober whatever you take a
mess they are put them in a place and
then as she says you wrap the services
around them you give them access to
everything
so in this in-home housing first thing
you don't expect them to fix their life
and then you reward them with a home
first you give them the home and then
that allows them to fix their life okay
so it's proved to be pretty successful
nine cities in the US including
Nashville have used this approach and it
has ended homelessness for veterans
three communities including including
Bergen County New Jersey which I didn't
know how to homeless problem but they do
they have ended chronic homelessness
completely which is kind of
rising okay Atlanta homelessness is down
29% New Orleans down 90% Finland is the
only European country that has where
homelessness is declining and there they
do this is what they do okay Utah is
down 91% when they instituted this
policy for this program and then they
decided to stop funding it and it went
back up again
okay so that all seems really good but
there's a little bit more the there are
economic benefits for this program
because homeless people are in and out
of shelters are in and out of hospitals
they're in and out of police and jails
and there's addiction centers and
there's all kinds of other things going
on once they have a home and they start
to kind of get things together then all
those expenses that the cities and other
places have start to go away Regina and
Canada saved 2.2 million when they
instituted this Finland is saving
eighteen eighteen and a half thousand
per person per year using this program
and it was calculated that Los Angeles
would save 33 million a year okay so
that is a kind of economic argument you
may think or some people may think that
homeless people are just fuck-ups and
they don't deserve to be just given a
home but no matter what your moral point
of view is whether they deserve it or
not it's it makes business sense it
makes a good economical sense to do this
for all of us so this one for example
this housing first seems to help us as
much as it helps them it helps the
society as a whole it saves us money so
it's hopefully being expanded
this kind of the economic effect of this
program reminded me of another one which
was is kind of in a certain way related
that there's a knock-on effect of
something that in some ways that you
wouldn't expect the University of
Pennsylvania oh I can do this
University of Pennsylvania did a study a
few years ago of cultural institutions
in New York City in the various boroughs
they looked at institutions like
libraries and little dance centers and
music things and all this kind of stuff
and they were looking mainly in middle
and lower class neighborhoods they
weren't looking at Lincoln Center or the
Museum museum of modern art or the
Whitney or any of those kind of places
they were looking at but and they wanted
to see what effects those places had on
the neighborhoods besides just being
like oh it's a library and go get books
they found out that in those
neighborhoods the test scores of the
kids went up 18 percent child abuse went
down 14 percent soul on this thing crime
went down 18 percent and obesity went
down five percent now to me that all
makes sense but I think to a lot of
people they would find that rather
surprising that the crime rate is
affected by libraries but it is and to
me that's great news okay now I'm gonna
jump to one that's maybe a little more
sting and probably the verdicts out a
little bit but it's it's a great story
these are people in a town called Tehran
and Michoacan in Mexico they're mainly
the community the little town is mainly
indigenous people and they have made
their living off the forest that
surrounds them is their kind of Commons
for years but in recent years illegal
loggers were coming into the forest and
along with that there were cartels and
everything else that were kidnappings
and
the things that come along with the
cartels the illegal loggers were taking
half of the wood from the forest so the
township of work feeling kind of how
helpless they went to the local their
local elected representatives in the
town and said can you stop this can you
do this and they said there's nothing
they were all in cahoots they were all
connected and they said no there's
nothing we can do about it so the people
in the town decided to take a radical
step the women in the town it's the
women who decided to take the step that
women early in the morning before some
sunrise block hated all the roads that
lead to the town in the forest and they
blocked these loggers coming in how they
didn't get killed they didn't but the
entire town then turned out to support
them so they they began by stopping the
loggers coming in then they kicked out
all the politicians they kicked out
but they banned political parties their
statement was that political parties
make people hate one another they put
people against one another so we got rid
of them they of course they got rid of
the police as well so well things don't
run themselves so yeah the women had to
train themselves how to how to use guns
and they they formed a some
organizations campfire meetings were
started to say well how we need
organizations to run the town we need to
just they haven't elected they
eventually had an elected council that
were selected at these fogatas these
campfires and so far it's doing pretty
well as they did before the land the
forest that they wear their Springs are
that they live off of in the wood and
everything else is shared in common
nobody owns any of it they all share it
they have a community police force which
is as you see in the picture crime
kidnappings all those things which used
to be among the highest in Mexico
Vishal Khan is a high crime state it
really ain't drop incredibly there's
hardly any crimes people feel safe women
can brought walk around the streets at
night and they feel safe so it's well it
sounds kind of ideal it's not perfect
and it's kind of unique because it's an
indigenous tribe an indigenous group
that lives there it's not like a city
like here where people from outside are
coming in and the population is changing
all the time the population is kind of
set they feel like this is their town
they have lived there for their parents
their grandparents everybody has lived
there there's a sense of unity that
allows that
helps them work together on all this
that is that's a hard thing to to
achieve but what's interesting is that
so far they've managed to do it a few
other mainly indigenous communities in
Mexico have been following their lead so
be curious to see what happens so that I
wondered about all these ideas and I've
stumbled upon another idea and I thought
what if somebody did something wonderful
there was a great idea that what people
were putting into effect technology that
people were using and then for some
weird reason it got forgotten and then
everybody thought oh of course once
things are forgotten you don't know
they're forgotten because they're not in
your head anymore and I stumbled upon a
paper by a scientific paper called
Sleeping Beauty's if we're how do we
find them how can we locate them whether
what are the qualities if it was a
scientific paper about what they called
Sleeping Beauty's and it was mainly
referring to science and they defined
them as scientific papers that got very
few citations when they came out and
then many years later 20 10 20 30 40 100
suddenly they'd be rediscovered and
there was this explosion of citations an
explosion of interest in this idea so it
was an idea that kind of lay dormant and
then suddenly was rediscovered of course
I applied it I thought of it as oh yes
it's like those you know record albums
that we all know about them to go this
is the greatest record ever why does
nobody know about it that kind of thing
so but it it calls into question a lot
of things
you start to wonder how often does this
happen and well the answer is it happens
fairly fairly regularly and they're not
exceptional this is what they discovered
in the paper they discovered that basing
the value of a technology a paper or
discovery of whatever on short term
citations a number of short term
citations is a kind of biased way of
looking at it because longer term and
where we are long now
longer term something may not get very
many citations and then suddenly it gets
discovered and it has a huge number of
citations and has an inordinate
influence on science and whatever else
from it from that point sometimes the
influence of these Sleeping Beauty's
once they wake up is is greater than the
things that got lots of citations when
they were first published and lastly
they pointed out that they are
discovered often by outsiders they're
often discovered by people outside the
field in which the paper was published
which is in a way not a surprise people
within the field or tend to think in
prescribed ways and they may not notice
something that is proposing a paradigm
or something that's outside of their
wearing thinking thinking so I started
thinking about this a little bit more
and I realized that we know about the
known unknowns I'm going to talk like
Donald Rumsfeld here for a while
the known unknowns for example are the
the Mayan codex is there were thousands
of Mayan codex s and now there are three
so we know that they're missing we know
that there are two Shakespeare plays
they're missing Love's Labour's won and
Cardenio we know that twenty books of
the Old Testament are missing and we
know that some of the books of the New
Testament are missing including the
gospel of Eve yes what would that have
been we all want to know this was in the
news fairly recently this is a Libra the
apt mates
this is okay we've just have to there
was an article about it recently and
there's a book about the guy who made
this book who is Hernando Cologne
Columbus's illegitimate son he had two
illegitimate sons and this one Hernando
decided kind of after his father's death
that he would attempt to collect every
book in the world from the Library of
Alexandria but even more he wasn't just
going to collect the great works of
literature and science he was going to
collect those but also every alamin act
every newspaper every printed material
bit of printed material he could lay his
hands on basically he wanted to have the
Internet in physical form and I'm not
sure where he was going to have it in
severe severe or some place he was very
good at categorizing things of course if
you have that many books he had at least
11,000 possibly 20,000 no we had about
at least 20,000 books it's estimated
[Music]
11,000 of those are
but we know they're missing only
recently what's this book discovered
this is the libro de las opiniones which
it is the kind of the card catalogue in
a way the key to the other books he
hired he hired other people to read
through all the other books and make
little summaries of them all and this is
this is what this is this was lost for
mm how many years so many years the way
you know well it was this book was found
in 2013 in Copenhagen and it was 1,500
or so when he started his library
collection so you know five thousand
five hundred years or so so now this
book tells us what's missing we can't we
don't know where they were but that his
categories that he had for the books
were maybe not the Dewey Decimal System
one section was called the the library
of shipwrecked books because those books
were lost in shipwrecks so they were
category but they didn't actually exist
okay moving on this is uh
Democritus Democritus this is the atom
of course he proposed I'm gonna go in
chronological order more or less he
proposed this and so now we're in real
Sleeping Beauty's that was kind of
things that we know were lost these are
things that were known talked about
discussed and then kind of forgotten the
atom 400 BC 22 centuries before it got
accepted it was a man named John Dalton
in 1808 who reap opposed the idea that
the basic unit is something called an
atom he used the same word
okay that I can't resist this the the
reason the idea of the atom or less as
we know it although he he thought a bit
more as a philosophical as a thought
experiment he couldn't prove that they
existed so it's like Einsteins thought
experiments he said this is what it has
to be but I can't prove it
anyway the reason why that was pushed
aside was because of Aristotle who his
idea was elements not atoms earth air
fire water and he was considered such a
learned and great man that everybody
accepted that for centuries and
centuries okay next
and then of course now we think of atoms
as well yeah concrete concrete about 200
BC concrete was used by the Romans this
is the pantheon yes Pantheon in Rome
it's still to this day at the largest on
you know unsupported unfort know kind of
rebar in there concrete dome in the
world kind of amazing
they had a formula for concrete that
used ash from a particular volcano that
was mixed in the formula was kind of
lost it was kind of rediscovered how
many years ago
45 years ago now could be it was
rediscovered fairly recently many
centuries later the concrete that we use
now is I think stronger but not as long
lasting as the Roman concrete so we've
never we haven't kind of got it back
completely but so for centuries concrete
was just not used at all
this is the Antikythera device which
were discovered in a shipwreck that it's
estimated that it was made about in
about 100 BC it was a device with 37
gear wheels that could predict the
movements of the planets of the Moon of
the Sun predict eclipses etc etc here's
a kind of computer rendering of the same
thing here is kind of a slice of all the
different gears that technology
disappeared and it wasn't until the
1300s that the mechanical technology
could duplicate what that machine did
kind of hard to believe but yes these
kind of things get forgotten this is
kind of a fun one that's the steam
engine we can to give it to James Watt
but it was a guy named Heron of
Alexandria and about 40 ad he's also
known as hero depending on where you
come from so he made one like this
whether steam he made a few different
versions
he made one like this where the steam
you know invasive it just the ball turns
and the steam comes out the things okay
nice but then he made one at a temple
where a similar kind of mechanism exists
underneath the temple
and when it turns it's attached to ropes
and the ropes magically open the door to
the temple so now the steam engine is
actually doing work then okay he did
other things as well he made the first
vending machine you'd put a coin in you
put a coin in I think it might have been
in the top and it dispensed holy water
okay
he also made a wind the first wind
driven machine which of course played a
musical instrument repair DeMorgan okay
so someone on the Internet of course
said well they had all the technology
they could have had trains or cars run
by this steam engine at that point but
they didn't which is another that's
probably another story why do some
things get to a certain point and then
they just you realize just one more step
and you'd have you could be you know
moving stones and temples and everything
around with these kind of vehicles but
they didn't work any so I'll come back
to James Watt and the rest of it later
there was a accurate clocks accurate
clocks this is a clock from that Wow who
was it think Persia he gave it he gave
it as a gift to Constantine in 8 807
nobody had seen anything like it it was
again a very complicated mechanism it
didn't have hands like we know instead
it had little doors that opened each
hour a door opened and little balls came
out so the ball in the balls dropped
down and hit a little like a little Gong
so not only could you tell what time it
is by looking at seeing how many doors
were open but it would announce itself
with these little gongs in 1770
uh-uh European technology was kind of
catching up to the Persians by that
point and Voltaire saw this device and
wondered how could they have known how
to do this it was kind of it's hard to
imagine sometimes that other people the
other people who seem foreign and
distant and strange could have SEC
developed a technology that has been
beyond us for centuries but they did
there's another diagram one might say
that okay here's another one oh wow I'm
gonna skip this binary numbers that's
kind of in dispute who when who actually
came up with binary numbers so we're
gonna do that but oh yes there's a steam
I'm gonna go to the steam engine part
two okay so I just generally credited to
James Watt but not quite a guy named
Jane thomas Saveur Saberi
in 1698 worked with Thomas Newcomen and
in 1712 they came up with this kind of
steam engine that had basically no
moving parts just the valves going up
and down what James Watt who was can
given the credit often for the steam
engine was aware of this saw this and
refined him and he developed his in 1775
of course we remember that it was at 40
AD when the first one was a very similar
to this one was invented and then many
many many centuries later it kind of
things get picked up again what it turns
out was quite the monopolist once he got
his IP his patent for his steam engine
he crushed all competition people
invented steam engines that were better
than Watts steam engine but he crushed
them okay
this is a this is an antiseptic okay
this is a good story aghh NASA some of
ice 1847 he worked in a maternity
hospital in Vienna now there were two
wards one was run by man and one was run
by midwives the women in the ward run by
men tended to get sick a lot
there was called child bed fever
something and they would die not all of
them but in alarming numbers the ones
being tended drugged by the midwives
didn't die anywhere near as much he
couldn't figure out why this was there
were priests that came through ringing
bells and he thought that was making
every everybody very anxious so he said
stop doing that it didn't make any
difference he there was another he tried
something else
oh yes the midwives tended to have the
women give birth on their sides so he
said everybody do that and that didn't
make a difference either then he noticed
that the male doctors were also
performing the autopsies on the women
who passed away and then they'd go back
and kind of deliver more babies and he
thought they might be on their fingers
carrying what he called cadaverous
particles germs the idea of germs had
not come into being yet he wanted to
kill these cadaverous particles so he
developed a kind of carbolic nose his
bizarre kind of chlorine wash that's him
washing his hands with chlorine
and it worked it worked but he was the
doctors didn't like the idea that they
were being it was inferred that they
were dirty the doctors they didn't like
this doctors at that point used to wear
smocks and that were splattered with
blood like butchers and they were these
were badges of honor because it showed
like this is what I do they reverted to
the old practice and stopped washing and
the deaths went back up
Cemil vice eventually goes mad and he
dies of sepsis an infection that could
have been stopped by someone washing
their hands ok so then it goes to look
at things that are a little bit more
well known pastor does his paper in 1867
that's about 20 years later the germ
theory and Joseph Lister in Scotland and
in Glasgow thinks this might be
something to try so he makes a spray a
spray device that sprays carbolic acid
over the patient over the big open wound
during surgery and it works it works it
lowers the deaths considerably
he was also mocked its scientific
gatherings the British medical
publication The Lancet okay and let's
see about five or six years later
officially warned doctors from following
pastoral Istres sprayed things and so it
fell out of favor but some people
believed in it in 1902 this is about 30
years later Lister has retired the King
of England
and we're the seventh has an
appendicitis he has to have surgery and
there's a very strong risk that he will
die the doctor who's going to operate on
him believes what Lister has done he
gets in touch with them and Lister
instructs him step by step this is what
you do he does it the king lives and
that's kind of the word gets out this
technique saved the Kings this is 1902
now okay now we're moving on to this is
I skipped something I skipped genetics
that's that's okay there's lots of
there's lots of them Gregor Mendel of
course it's his idea of what he didn't
call them genes but he knew there was
something in there that was changing
plants and this was 1866 it was not
accepted for about thirty four years and
the reason it wasn't accepted at least
in some things that I've read was really
interesting Darwin Darwin who gets the
blame for genetics not being accepted
Darwin's theory came out just before
this and Darwin's idea that evolution
change happens really really slowly
incrementally in tiny tiny steps Mendel
of course said no you put the right
genes there and this one that used to be
you know a red peed comes out as a white
pee you know just like that it changes
from this to this and Mendel was also
saying it's the same species
it hasn't changed because one is red and
one is flight or whatever that doesn't
mean it's a different species then
everybody was in thrall to Darwin at the
time
so for about 34 years that wasn't not
accepted and then gradually a group of
scientists repeated Mendel's experiments
and said no he's right
dark matter oh my god okay dark matter
was proposed by Lord Kelvin in 1902 yeah
in 1933 Fritz Zwicky yeah began to see a
convent of course no one but no one
believed him Kelvin in 33 Zwicky said
I'm starting to see a conflict between
of course galactic motion the motions of
the of the stars and what we think the
gravity should be there's something
missing he said I think he might have
been right
the idea was resisted until the 60s and
now of course we all realized that only
4% of the universe is visible to us the
rest of it is dark matter and dark
energy
Einstein it's a really famous one
Einstein's paper on quantum was done in
1935 and ignored more or less for 60
years he he said the paper was down yeah
the paper was about he doubted that
quantum theory was a complete
description and in 1994 it was kind of
resurrected and taken seriously
okay I'm gonna skip some things Asperger
okay
he was yeah okay I mean it's it's sad
okay Asperger we've pretty well known
now he called his charges the little
professors and he believed that these
kids with extraordinary abilities were
in various ways of benefit to society
Hitler killed them all
but the idea now has kind of begun to be
resurrected this is her on the picture
is Herman Minsky 1974 he proposed an
economic theory that said that stability
but gets crashes that when things are
going well the banks start to lend
because everything's going better and
better and people are going to be able
to pay it back
I could go on and on but that's you get
the idea things get more and more
precarious the better they are
inevitably it crashes nobody wanted to
hear this it it you know standard
economic theory this is just like no no
no no no when things are going wrong
well they're doing well
so of course 2007 everybody starts to go
wasn't there that guy that kind of was
talking about this and why this happened
yes okay so now I'm going to quickly go
into the arts a little bit
this is broy a painting by Bruegel Roy
goal was very popular quite popular when
he began to paint and then at some point
he was considered a peasant he wasn't he
didn't go to an academy and he painted
excuse me
peasant rituals who's considered a
primitive
I think was the king of Habsburg Empire
somebody collected basically all his
work loved him at the time basically
then put him out of circuit put the work
out of circulation inferior copies began
to circulate tastes changed and he
became for quite a few centuries
considered not very interesting the the
Emperor began to sell off the pictures
and now they're scattered all over the
place in museums everywhere but it
wasn't until the early 20th century that
people began to look at his work and see
a connection with modernism they saw
that Bruegel was painting the world the
world of the or of ordinary people and
somehow this connected with a seemed a
very modern idea and so he was kind of
resurrected this is some people know who
this is this is Hilma of clint she was a
painter in Sweden she was a mediumistic
painter she would had go into you know
seances and she's 1906 she painted a lot
of big abstract paintings she was
considered the first abstract artist
there's debate about this but mmm yeah
yeah she was ahead of Mondrian ahead of
Kandinsky yes except for excetera
so she there are aspersions cast on her
partly one might say maybe because she's
a woman
maybe maybe because she claimed that it
was spirits who were guiding her work
and they were so there the critics would
say well see it's it's not really her
so when it's about 19 so OH
some things happened in her life some
unfortunate things huge adored with the
work and the teachings of Rudolf Steiner
Steiner came to see her in Stockholm and
looked at her work and and disapproved
of him she had been showing some of this
work not these giant ones but she'd been
showing some so that and the kind of
lack of understanding and of the work
that she was doing she decided she was
her time was wrong she decided to hide
it away and she in her will she said
don't open this until 20 years after I'm
dead so she became the agency that put
herself her own work to sleep her nephew
was in charge of executing her will
which he did he opened it might have
been in whatever in the 70s I think
1970s maybe and he began to try and have
it be seen by more widely he offered the
entire collection of I think it was
1,200 paintings to the modern Museum in
Stockholm and they've turned it down
eventually it's been accepted there's
been a big show at the Guggenheim I saw
did a show in Sao Paulo
the show that's pictured here is at the
modern Museum in Stockholm music this is
Frank Johnson it was a recent piece I
think it was in The New Yorker about him
or maybe it was another publication
anyway he was incredibly popular
he led what would be called a string
band there were there was such a thing
as afro-american string bands they were
incredibly popular he was one
popular artists in the country when he
passed away in Wilmington Delaware it
was the largest funeral that Wilmington
had ever seen and then around the tower
turn of the century turn of 20th century
the idea of afro-american string bands
begins to kind of be pushed aside and
there's a shift in taste and a [ __ ]
shift in attribution string bands are
something that white people do so
this his music began became basically
unknown string band music fiddles and
reels and all all this began to be
considered late person white people's
music there was a bit of white supremacy
in this kind of attribution but that's
what happened and then many years later
there were groups not that long ago ten
years ago maybe like the Carolina
Chocolate Drops I think there's a
picture of them later on we started
reviving his his work this is a
Brazilian group that I championed and
other people that does well Beck and
Kurt Cobain in other words I love this
group they're the O's Mutantes they made
incredible records like in 1969 and then
they kind of they kind of disappeared
the records went out of print people in
Brazil would tell me about this amazing
group and how inventive they were but of
course you could not get the records
anywhere and then yes maybe 25 years or
so after that there was reissues in
Japan and my little label did an issue
of some of their things in a big kingdom
so these things come back to life The
Velvet Underground as Brian Eno said
they only sold a handful of records but
everybody who bought a record started a
band which
and it's kind of true yeah which goes
back to the first thing the kind of the
citations and the scientific papers if
you consider record sales as like
citations they were very low but they
were very influential and then as time
goes by there's more and more of them
and in the audience grows so I start to
ask myself why I've answered some of
these questions but why do these things
go to sleep
is it a jealous jealous mother-in-law or
whatever the mother the most
all-encompassing reason is context why
are things go to sleep because of
context there is a technical context
like with the the Greek thing with the
gears we forget the technique we forget
the recipe for contract for concrete or
how to machine gears accurate enough to
predict the movements of the planets and
then we rediscover the technology which
allows us to rediscover these devices
there's an economic context things are
invented and ideas proposed but nobody
can figure out what the practical
application might be yeah well what if
it how do we make money out of that or
what good is that gonna be to anyone
nobody can see what it what use it might
be it goes to sleep
of course there's social biases whether
that's racism or other kinds of things
and there's let's say yes intellectual
context ideas that hold sway like the
Darwin story of
versus gregor mendel there's racism
nationalisms xenophobia those put things
to sleep and make have very strange
ideas one of my favorites is Darwin of
course withheld his own book Origin of
Species
partly because part of the story is that
he suddenly published it because he
realized Wallace and others were going
to publish their versions and he had to
get his out but it was also because of
his wife who was a deeply religious
woman and he loved her very much
and he knew that his book would be would
be very very disturbing to her and it
might break up their marriage and so he
withheld it number of decades language
communication things are the clock
mechanism in Persia that Europe seemed
to be completely unaware of scale things
like the concrete the Roman concrete
couldn't have been made without the the
whole mechanism of getting the ash from
this one volcano working with it in
sufficient quantity moving it from place
to place there's a whole kind of chain
of things that has to be in place for
this one thing to to be made and once
those wants pieces of that chain fall
out it can't be done anymore the formula
it's forgotten okay why do they wake up
I ask myself well I've answered some of
those too one of them is people a paper
about some by people look oh my god I
wrote it in with some sort of poetic
thing it says look nearby but it which
is which is true people look it has
something close to something else and
they go oh look at that
another one is help from a friend help
from a friend so for instance someone
champions like a hilma's nephew or
others where someone is a champion of an
idea someone doesn't drop the ball and
goes with it someone as I said someone
looks elsewhere so rather than someone
in one discipline it's someone in
another discipline who looks and goes
that's an incredible idea
I can maybe apply it to my own work to
my own kind of area of expertise and
there's a reputation gets reassessed
that's easy to understand oh here's a
fun one whether I was reading about the
Little Ice Age which took place in 1500
to like 1700 I think the devastated
European agriculture as a result
according to one writer the Europeans
were forced to expand their point of
view expand where they were their trade
etc because their own fields were
failing and by doing so they came into
contact with other ideas other
technologies and other ways of thinking
and you kind of give credit to the
weather else do I have in here
this is a sleeping period of being woken
up but I'm sad to say if anyone's come
across the real original folktale
he rapes her yeah it's not a kiss she
has two children while she's still
asleep one of the children the thorn you
know the the splinter that put her to
sleep one of the children
finds her breast the other one can't
find the other breast starts sucking on
the finger and sucks out the splinter
and she wakes up yeah
okay so all this I started to ask myself
what have I learned well you know I
learned about Lister and his problems
and the card catalogue of every bit of
knowledge we possibly have
but there's okay in a more meta sense I
realized that we think I'm as guilty as
this is anyone we think that knowledge
is an endless accumulation there you
just you add to what came before which
we do and it just it never goes away you
keep adding more and more and more and
it builds up and it's all getting
greater and greater obviously not quite
true we think that these silly people
from the 17th century or the medieval
folks or whatever they are just not as
smart as we are that that's why they
forgot these things that's why they lost
the recipe for concrete they lose it
they must have been you know idiots so
we think that we're wiser than people
were in the past we've as Donald
Rumsfeld would say these are the unknown
unknowns when something is forgotten
we're unaware that it is just so we have
no knowledge that oh we lost the recipe
for concrete maybe we see this Doman we
go oh man how did they do that but we
don't know but we don't we don't know
that what's missing because because it's
missing and I broke down some little
thing
abandonment letting a knowledge or
technology go is a kind of filter might
not be a good filter but sometimes it
might be a necessary filter rediscovery
then which is also selective is another
filter so things are getting filtered
now twice we find the future our own
future the future of everyone sometimes
we find it in the past rather than
looking at the here and now and looking
forward and we should maybe turn around
and see what happened before that we
missed
so to go forwards sometimes we first
have to go back that's the end all right
I ran over a little bit but I'm sorry
that's great let's sit
well that well that is fun stuff she
totally is fun it's way more of a long
now talk than I really expected frankly
and you know some colleges are now
dropping history from their curriculum
they are they're making mistake and
there's a complaint among some engineers
that the history of engineering is not
taught and that sounds like a quite a
mistake as well yeah we think not
not that you need to know all the
details but you need to know the process
and a question from Rebecca what is
something that people are excited about
now you think that might easily be
forgotten now that you've seen a bunch
of things that I mean some of them were
obscured then and they just didn't come
out until later but some like the black
string band guy were popular at the time
but then somehow it got lost and now how
do you I'm in my late 60s now okay are
you probably seen a few things that have
gone through that cycle they were
popular you know they're good you know
they're kind of long-term good that they
dropped away any examples that come to
mind or a sense of how that works in
modern times how do these things get
lost my mind is going blank do you have
I do you have anything that's so any
gonna yell something out people get a
question coming up yeah but it's
something to bear in mind you know what
is the process now because one of the
things you are looking at is it various
times the mechanisms of forgetting the
filter that was applied was different at
the time and one of the things that
courage to me is now maybe it was social
media mainly the fact that books don't
caught a print anymore that there's more
stuff being looked at by more people
with this kind of discerning eye
a year if it's music that may give more
of a chance for things to bubble back
just because there's such a wide range
of search going on it was used to be
just a few people can search mm-hmm now
in the sense everybody can so that may
affect things search it but as you're
saying search is governed by algorithms
and the algorithms or the filter okay
what are your algorithms for search yeah
what are my outdoor rhythms yeah I mean
you scan you're a scholar music among
other things oh and you scan for these
things what are you looking for you
looking for what is it that you uniquely
are noticing how do you how do you
advise people to look there's something
that catches my attention or interest in
the first place and that's the part I
don't completely understand it then I
tend to follow that down the rabbit hole
I'll follow links or if there's a name
that's mentioned I'll go okay who is
that so you actually spend time online
going yes but it's it's it's but then I
end up with all these little stories and
I go these are incredible stories I'm
gonna tell my friends some of this stuff
it occurred to me one one thing would be
good to know is at the beginning you
were talking about the good ideas or the
reasons to be cheerful is there an
online version of all that the people
can discover not yet we put it we put
him hit the pause button it should be
activated again in August so there'll be
a website of recent webiste for whatever
it is okay as of August and now what
would they search for that'll be it
reasons to be cheerful and there'll be
all these kind of stories posted not the
sleeping beauty stories the
posted yeah a couple of times a week and
then since I got is that you were
looking to see if I got the criteria
right you were looking for things that
were just an idea they were actually
working in the world they had to be
actually working and that they might
they didn't seem to be so unique to the
situation of the creator where they
occurred that they could be more widely
applied in the world exactly I didn't
want something where it only applied to
one culture mm-hmm in well that's great
for them but so they're starting with
homes for the homeless which is how you
begin the talk that has now been done
several different places it sounds like
and it's been successful pretty much
everywhere but as you were asking about
what things could be forgotten
look Utah did it it was successful and
then they defunded it which is kind of
like are you why would you do this
well politics probably politics maybe
the the whole idea of giving homes to
people who you know people might morally
think these people don't deserve homes
but it's economically it pays for itself
well may its prey asked quarters and
Sleeping Beauty's from your own
catalogue of work your catalogue of work
is the broadest of any artist I know I'm
gonna have more books and music and
plays and
and some of that you know and deeply
your spec you know it's pretty good but
it somehow it got lost in the mix any of
those who want to celebrate Italy I mean
there's there's things that didn't
connect the way I maybe hoped they would
a number of years ago I did a musical
about Joan of Arc
it got savaged by the New York Press and
basically that was that was the end of
it but I thought let me look at it and
see if I they might have had a
points if maybe there's kind of I hope
not too many but let's see if this any
of that can be resurrected so do you go
back to work sometimes so you think you
have merit that you'd like to give her
another shot at yeah really
what are some of the ones you've done
that's one where I thought I haven't
done it yet but I thought there might be
a way to rework that somehow and make it
into something but who knows then I'll
find out if it's yeah if it has merit or
not you're I sort of know you sir Brian
you know cuz a friend and an associate
was long now for a long time and your
collaboration with him has been amazing
in terms of the product but your
collaborative generally you seem very
comfortable working with other artists
and and out of the interplay getting
some extra thing is that yeah say more
about how that works for you for me when
a collaboration works and it it can work
fairly often mm-hmm pretty good
percentage of times you get something
extra you get something that neither of
the collaborators would have done on
their own and and both of them or
however many there are realize oh this
is greater than the sum of its parts or
it's a third thing that has come into
existence that is neither of us but it's
something of something else it doesn't
always work I mean there's some times
when it just doesn't but when it does
that's really exciting I've heard other
musicians say kind of that they hate the
idea of collaborations
really so some it feels to them that it
is watering down the authenticity of the
of the author it's a compromise of some
sort which which it is you're inevitably
compromising but if you get something
greater they'll to me and that's worth
it see a little more about Brian you
guys go
back to the 70s I guess yeah musicians
came out of art schools and then how did
you intersect and it was my life in the
bush of ghosts the beginning of the
collaboration where did it go
it was before before that record Brian
worked with a couple of Talking Heads
records I was before that record we met
at a little Club in in London when we
first played there and we and we became
friends we had interests in common mmm
outside of music and so we've just had a
correspondence and a friendship and that
seemed to be there was something more
valuable about that about working with
someone where they're kind of with a
point of view mm-hmm that was broader
than just music that you can share that
that seemed to be something that we felt
more comfortable with than just someone
who was a skilled musical technician so
this song that we saw at the beginning
one fine day which I guess was part of
an element he did together I know the
story and I think this group might be
kind of interested how you guys
collaborated on that song and that album
[Music]
it was an album for a few years ago and
Brian had musical tracks music but very
very little words and vocal melodies
mm-hmm and I said let me let me have a
go at some of these and see if I can
write lyrics and a melody on top of it
and i sat with it Burton yeah maybe a
year before I before I felt like okay I
think I know what the approach did this
material is and that was that was the
first song him came back to him with he
loved it um
unknown to me I think he'd given the
same track or something to the guys in
Coldplay I didn't know but I think
generously I think he played what I'd
done to them and they said no that's it
so the sense I got from him is basically
you guys were not together in a studio
you did the whole thing by email yeah
emails
oh that's most of them then we'll get
together every once in a while but yeah
which is actually probably pretty good
for collaborators in some kinds of waste
not think you can with exchanging things
that way you can sit on something and
not be not have the pressure to react to
what someone else has done immediately
because that might be the wrong reaction
it might take a minute to kind of think
oh let me absorb what they've done and
respond to it give it a little time to
sink in because it's always a shock
because what they've done to your child
right so it's a shock and then you can't
go I think I get this then yeah so in
that case were you sort of coming up
with lyrics and he was doing some music
around it or yes and that one
the division of labor was very pretty
pretty clear pretty much I was doing
lyrics and some vocal melodies some came
from him and then singing it and then he
had done pretty much all the
instrumental music mm-hmm very easy very
clear division of labor on that one I
thought that made the collaborative
process easier when you know when there
when there's rules yeah
bill landers ask were you able to bike
right today where did you go yes this
guy wrote a book called the bicycle
Diaries tell us a little about bicycling
and today I went I went downtown but
then went out by Dogpatch and what's it
go India
something yeah and which is an area I
wasn't familiar with and I could see oh
this is area it's changing but Tesla
most changing not as fast as some other
areas kind of still remnants of old
industry of San Francisco when it was a
large port before Oakland took over that
you're very judgmental about various
cities in terms of how good they are to
bike in how did the San Francisco rate
in that well other than the hills san
francisco's pretty good it's very good I
mean there's bike lanes and they're
there you don't see too many cars
parking in the bike lanes it's pretty
good did you see the play Arcadia by Tom
Stoppard no I didn't worth doing I just
mentioned it because it is very much in
the line of basically complexity theory
is invented by this young lady in the
1700s and then has forgotten the world
because she dies young and the course of
the play basically explains don't worry
these things may be lost but they're not
lost they are returned and it's probably
you Stoppard specially I'll bet you
enjoy it I don't check it out
I guess McGrath asks what is the common
thread in overcoming one sight diced so
I would suggest partly is knowing the
zeitgeist I know just doing musicians
I'm shocked at the amount of knowledge
of what other musician
they're doing that musicians seem to
have an artisan showing Brian's line is
art is about art the sense that artists
are aware in their various domains of
what has gone on in what is now going on
in their world that's a little and there
they've got the zeitgeist down cold and
they want to depart from that in some
fashion is that how it works or
something else entirely
no and for me I I'm not sure but for me
I feel like if I pay too much too much
of love you know listening to music and
other people what hearing what other
people are doing but I also feel like
I'll get inspiration from this kind of
stuff I'll greet about mm-hmm a story or
whatever and I'll see it as a kind of
allegory or a metaphor or something I go
now can I take that and somehow apply it
hmm to music not necessarily write a
song about mm-hmm right exactly
think about that process and is there
kind of is there a way to kind of mimic
or draw inspiration from that process
what comes to mind examples of that for
you Wow so an idea that came from
elsewhere that became well okay one
thing that some years ago I was
rehearsing for a tour and I knew that I
wanted to have some dancers on stage
with me and so we were auditioning
dancers and one of the choreographers
there were 50 dancers in the room and
one of the choreographers said okay
here's what you do there's like once you
do all do something in in there's a few
rules we're gonna play some music
everybody moved to it however you like
find a phrase by phrase she meant you
know like four bars of the music find
that and make your own movement kind of
movement that goes with that if you find
something you like repeated that was the
first rule the next rule was as you're
doing that you're kind of looping your
movement look around you and if you see
somebody else doing something better
than what you're doing switch over and
do and do what they're doing oh my god
and the third rule was when everybody's
doing exactly the same thing it's over
it took four minutes for 50 people to
sure all be doing exactly the same thing
was it pretty good watching that thing
it was the faucet it was white like
watching evolution in in high speed you
know and high motion because you'd see
you'd see a little cluster of like
motion over here and emerging in the
back and another one over here and this
one's growing faster than that one and
then this one meets that one and it
takes it over oh my god
and then grad you know that kind of
thing come watch it all happening very
very quickly it's pretty great
that way it would seem like okay there
was a metaphor for a lot of my
biological phenomena and cellular
phenomena but having kind of human
beings in a kind of movement and
creative social thing did that lead any
work by you
you mentioned Edison inspiration it did
maybe I didn't try to do anything just
like that but I thought kind of
emergence that kind of idea a couple of
simple rules and you can get something
really all right
that is you don't know where it came
from
all right incredibly complex and you
only set a few simple rules in motion so
Brian does a lot of generative music and
now generative painting sort of based on
some of that concept are you doing
generative work that has that quality a
few rules and then you let it loose not
so much
Eve herself the gospel of Eve gospel you
know I was sitting here with Kevin Kelly
he was a heart / Christian and I was so
what's the Gospel of Eve I don't know
it's missing
[Applause]
are we entirely sure you didn't just
make up that cuz you can make up
anything that's just sort of made up
anything I could have made up anything
Hanna who would Stu who would say oh no
no that's going too far
so Eve says a beautiful clear writing is
there anything there's anything that
would be beneficial to forget and in a
sense you know do that but also looking
at just in certain current context with
everything that once it becomes a
digital sort of doesn't disappear the
way it used to and is the are the things
that you consider it will be beneficial
to forget that's the filter that should
be applied and what does the actual way
that things can be forgotten and now now
it's one of the functions of fashion is
to constantly say pay no attention to
that because that was last year now this
year were all the attention to X and
fashion is constantly trying to bury
things but is that the only way things
get buried you what came to mind was one
of the things I didn't mention which was
a in the I guess the Renaissance it was
it became fashionable to portray the
previous centuries as being the Dark
Ages and that the idea was put forward
that no we're good
civilization had quote fallen asleep and
we were going to look back to the
classics Greek and Roman and that was
going to be our inspiration
we're gonna leapfrog and then we're
gonna build on that hmm
my own thought was okay fine but that in
certain ways it it might be better to
forget ideas like that and have a more
open mind and look at what happened
during the medieval and Gothic era and
go mm-hmm maybe that wasn't don't place
a value judgment on it it was a
different way of looking at things a
different way of rendering images and
thinking and being it it's wrong to
maybe put a value judgment on it and
that's what you should forget mm-hmm end
with a question about your process
you're incredibly prolific you do a wide
range of things seemingly simultaneously
just not tracking your every movement
uh-huh and their most recent speaker Ian
McEwan I got sort of going on what does
it take for him to get from novels a
novel and how long does it take and
what's his expectation of as he goes
into it how long's it gonna take and
things like that do you have any kind of
a process that you now notice works for
you on how you move from project to
project how you sort of foster ideas
that are cooking in your mind how do you
decide what to do next and after that
how do you manage your creativity hmm
yeah obviously it has to be selective
this there's too many things that are
interesting that seems like oh that
would be a really exciting thing to be
doing but you can't do them all I have
to make a choice some things maybe get
chosen because you feel like I think I
know how to do that I can see where
that's gonna go
maybe you ever hint that way and
sometimes maybe the exact opposite you
go
I'm incredibly drawn to this but I have
no idea where it's gonna go and that
might be the reason um wow it's so you
trust me in a sense your curiosity and
your that looks interesting and you've
learned to finesse that in some fashion
so it leads you to things that you feel
good doing and feel good having a gun
yeah and it's I mean I'm lucky enough
that I've managed to not get stuck in a
rut in a way not get to pigeon-holed so
I can do what I've done tonight yeah the
choice you made at some point or is that
just build anything I think there might
have been a choice at some point I mean
I saw other people that were kind of
doing that and I thought that's the way
to do this mm-hmm and then you have you
have you can keep more options open
thank you all thank you keeping up the
fantastic work
you
[Music]